good morning John happy pizza miss I
know I'm still on paternity leave but I
made this video early because I felt
really bad that I wasn't gonna be able
to make pizza miss video right now I'm
walking to a place where a bunch of
people who I like make a bunch of stuff
that I like and I wanted to show it off
it's Pizza miss specific I don't know
why I'm trying to be like oblique you're
gonna find out right now
[Music]
this is Sioux City apparel they've been
printing shirts for us for almost three
years now and they print pretty much
every shirt that we sell at dftba
I asked them if I could go visit during
this year's pizza miss printing and they
graciously accepted and even amazingly
provided me with pizza so let's meet
some of these people this is Chris he
owns ooh City why did you start a print
shop I have no idea how long ago was
that now ten years oh my god this is Lou
he's one of the press operators started
in my garage about 17 I went to school
for graphic design then it took 20 years
for it to come back around I'm gonna go
ahead and set it around just this sir
yeah and if you want to walk around
it'll go through every handle print just
this shirt right
completely different when it comes out
the back this is Corey
he's the ink guy he listen to podcasts
while you're doing this oh yeah oh yeah
years before you walked in here that's
printing a shirt isn't like printing
from a printer the colors get made the
inks get mixed by Corey sometimes he has
a formula to start with but he usually
ends up eyeballing it and the color ends
up looking different on the shirt than
it does in the bucket so it's a skill
that can only be developed with time we
work with Sioux City because they make a
fantastic product they care about making
our shirts fantastic and they know how
to get it done I love watching them
utilize their skills to do great work
and I'm very glad they were okay with me
jumping on their space to appreciate
them making our stuff I think for the
most part businesses want you to imagine
that the things that you buy are made in
Star Trek style replicators because
that's simple and they don't want to
complicate the transaction they want you
to think about the thing not the people
who made it not necessarily because
those people aren't happy in their jobs
just because it complicates things but I
think it's nice and also maybe important
to see a bit of the complexity and the
hard work that goes into the things that
I buy and the things that I sell it
might not be simple but I think it's
more rewarding and it's definitely more
real and frankly it's too easy to never
appreciate all of the people who work
hard making their lives and everyone
else's lives a little bit better every
day
John happy beats honest I'll see you
tomorrow and you will see me when I get
back from paternity leave
[Music]
me like that back in line
don't
[Music]
Oh
leave your message of the time
was you not me
[Music]